everyone Ryan and I recently called a
truce in our social media war and we
promise to make ads for each other
yeah I'm sure did I've been working 24/7
on an ad for Hugh's incredible coffee
company Laughing Man yeah and he's been
working hard 24/7 I imagine on a a v8
engine at so let's I'm gonna go first
let's yeah let's roll it
come on can a cup of coffee be a
superhero his laughing man beans are
born with a special power sure it's the
best tasting coffee in the market yeah
it awakens your senses with unbelievable
flavor but it also lifts up communities
around the world in the form of housing
and scholarships and who could be behind
such a heroic company you guessed it my
friend
Hugh Jackman the loving and caring man
who created laughing men make every cup
count Wow Wow man that was really that's
really professional it's like it costs a
million dollars
really yeah Wow um I I'm not quite ready
to show my new magnet and let's just cut
for a sec I know it's not what most
finished just some color correcting for
a second let's just roll it come on
almost there you go go go roll it roll
it Ryan Reynolds is a complete and total
the June's pretty great that I'll have
to try it someday sorry man I didn't
think the truce was actually real
so how do I like that everybody is
Charlie so Hugh Jackman and Ryan
Reynolds having a little bit of fun with
their Deadpool Wolverine rivalry they've
been doing this for a long time they've
had a war on social media supporting
each other's films doing a lot of parody
ads I'll play one of the funnier ones in
a second but we also got confirmation
from the x-men producers at Fox what's
gonna be happening with a new version of
Wolverine and what's gonna be happening
with all the x-men characters once Kevin
Feige gets them so we got to freak out
about that too don't worry we'll break
it all down there's a new route of the
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Deadpool Wolverine moment on
the video so Hugh Jackman Ryan Reynolds
haven't had the actual opportunity to do
a real Deadpool Wolverine team-up boobie
so they've been doing this for the past
couple of years this is probably one of
the best parodies that they've done
many actors enjoy performing their own
stunts yes do you do all your own acting
if there's sex scenes I do them yes
that's where the craft is yeah it's key
to a good marriage did you guys get any
notes from the studio - so Eddie's mouth
shut make lasers shoot from his eyes you
know I didn't but I thought it'd be a
great idea
as a story it totally makes sense 5%
always how do I open this up to a few
fan questions here that I got first one
comes from Brian Glenn olds from
Vancouver British Columbia I love Latin
America that's amazing
Brian asks Hugh I heard that on x-men
Wolverine mm-hmm you had specially
designed lifts put in your shoes and so
you would appear taller than one of your
co-stars is this true or just a silly
fact it's it's true I I did next
question but but it was a story reason
that everything in that movie was about
story in character sorry advancing it
you know so you've all heard the rumors
about Hugh Jackman there was even like a
crazy rumor that he was gonna show up an
Avengers end game that is patently not
true there is no Wolverine Hugh Jackman
in Avengers end game but all the
Wolverine news this week is actually
confirmed because Lauren Shuler Donner
who's been like the Fox version of Kevin
Feige for all the x-men movies ever
since the very first Bryan Singer x-men
movie was doing a big panel for Fox at
the TCA is talking about other Marvel
Fox related
television stuff people of course asked
her about the Fox Disney deal and what's
gonna be happening with some of these
characters so she actually gave some
really good answers she's the one that
confirmed what's going on with the
Wolverine character she also confirmed
what's going on with a lot of the x-men
projects that are going on right now
which ones are gonna get cancelled and
which ones Disney is probably gonna
continue on making but here's her full
quotes about the x-men characters in The
Wolverine character so she starts by
saying everything is on hold since
Disney took over those are the movies
that are in development right now like
the gambit movie the Doctor Doom movie
everything she says frankly I took a
step back after the first deadpool movie
because i was so successful so I wasn't
front and center at all for Apocalypse
talking about x-men apocalypse the new
mutants movie or Simon Kinberg x-men
Dark Phoenix he took over but these are
the things that I put in place saying
that she was responsible for those
movies getting greenlit and going into
production with gambit certainly it's
too bad that it's taking so long because
I really want to see that obviously
everybody's curious about what's gonna
happen to the gambit movie she goes on
to say but let's see let's hope so right
now it's all in Disney's hands we don't
know what they're gonna do so she's
saying like she's not really sure what's
gonna happen with the gambit movie it
could get made but she's saying that
it's kind of unlikely and she goes on to
say now it goes to Kevin Feige who was
my protege he and I started on that
first x-men movie together Kevin Feige
actually started out in Hollywood as a
really young person as her assistant he
got to be an assistant producer on that
first Bryan Singer x-men film he worked
on a couple more projects then he
officially went over to Marvel as they
were forming what became Marvel Studios
they asked her about what's going on
with Deadpool and recently Bob Iger did
an earnings call for Disney with all the
Disney investors in thankfully he
specifically said now this is him
publicly stating this that Disney will
continue to make r-rated Deadpool films
they're not gonna hobble him and make
him go pg-13 or anything like that now
that's just the Deadpool solo films and
whatever future spin-offs of the
Deadpool character they do like the
x-force movies that they wind up making
those if he winds up in an Avengers
movie he will be more in the tone of the
Avengers which are typically pg-13
movies so the really big Marvel
crossovers if they ever eventually
happened would be where you see pg-13
Deadpool but as long as he's in his own
movie by himself
he will be as r-rated as he's ever been
so don't worry about that
when people asked her if they are going
to recast the Wolverine character she
said yes she acknowledges is basically
time to pass the torch like that's the
executive level thinking right now like
they want to pass the torch to new
character Hugh Jackman in real life has
said that he wants to pass the torch
he's getting ready to go on tour for
like a one-man show so he's doing like a
lot of musical stuff so he'll be really
busy doing that in the next year anyway
her actual quote just reads yes because
Hugh just the physicality of it all just
to bulk up this man worked so hard to
bulk up he would get up at 4:00 in the
morning to bulk up and eat protein meals
every two hours because his natural
state they used to call him worm when he
was a kid so his natural state is a very
skinny guy once you reach a certain age
the body just won't go anymore I think
he was wise to say I'm at that point I
can't do it now that doesn't mean that
he can't come back as older Wolverine so
remember that old man Logan you never
know
future Wolverine you never know so that
is in line with what I've said about the
character before my early predictions
were is that what would happen is is
they do recast Wolverine then when they
eventually do another big multiverse
level Avengers crossover movie like
Avengers secret Wars you bring alternate
reality versions of him back or future
versions and he plays old man Logan
during the movie with the young version
of Wolverine that they've recast so
hopefully that clarifies what Kevin
Feige is thought process is like
definitely new Wolverine but definitely
trying to get hugh jackman coming back
to cameo as old man Logan eventually
Lauren Shuler Donner also goes on to
talk about how many Marvel movies Disney
is going to release every year once they
get all these extra x-men characters her
quote reads the problem is you can't
have too many Marvel x-men superhero
movies out there because they will
cancel each other out each one has to be
distinctive and yet you got the Avengers
movies to follow through you've got so
many distinctive story canons to follow
through and yet we want new ones but I
don't think that you could have more
than four per year for us a lot because
people are going to get sick of them and
we have to be careful he has to be
careful talking about Kevin Feige so
what that means is is right now without
the x-men characters Kevin Feige had
started to release three more
movies per year what'll probably happen
is eventually they'll work their way up
to four and you'll have like your early
movie like February March like Captain
Marvel is a March movie you'll have a
spring movie which this year is Avengers
endgame you'll have a movie during the
summer like June July then they'll do
their fourth movies sometime around
August or November towards the end of
the year now keep in mind though that
that does not include spider-man films
so really you're talking like five to
six films because now you have the main
Tom Hollands spider-man solo films but
you also have the venom franchise which
will be releasing films every couple of
years and you have the spider-man into
the spider-verse
animated films which because they made
so much money they'll be releasing
sequels every couple of years so we'll
still be getting the same number a big
comic book films it's just that more of
them will be coming from Disney and
obviously none of this includes any
potential x-men TV shows that they do on
the Disney Plus streaming service which
they did say that they are developing we
did find out that we're gonna get
trailers for all the Disney Plus
streaming shows at Star Wars Celebration
in April they're gonna do a big demo of
that streaming service and they'll have
probably a trailer for the Star Wars
Mandalorian TV show maybe they'll have
teasers for those live-action Avengers
movies with the Avengers actors so it'll
be really cool April is gonna be a
really big month because Game of Thrones
Season eight is premiering we're getting
Avengers endgame we're getting our first
trailer for Star Wars Episode nine and
trailers for all the really big stuff
that's coming at the end of the year so
everybody start freaking out about April
it's gonna be really awesome let me know
in the comments though Kevin Feige waits
till say like next year to officially
recast the Wolverine character who do
you want that new younger version of
Wolverine to be click here for all the
new different once upon a Deadpool
post-credit scenes and click here to
re-watch that Avengers end game Super
Bowl trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]